In these...
In these very dark times,
when there will no long be
an @midnight
and Kid Rock
could soon be making laws
and malt liquor dookies
on the Senate floor,
giant icebergs are breaking free
from their ancient moors
and hauling ass to Miami,
and health care
might soon just be
Trump just throwing pills out
the window of Air Force One.
Now we're all besieged
by the creeping premonition
that death will beckon sooner
than we thought
and that the only sounds left
to echo in our skulls
will be unholy wailing
and gnashing of teeth.
But don't worry,
because every cartoon
from the '90s
is getting a reboot! Yeah!
-(cheers and applause)
-Yeah. (whoops)
-Yeah.
-I'm in that one. Mm.
HARDWICK: Uh, anyway,
we can all wrap ourselves
in a warm nostalgia parka
for a few minutes
'cause every cartoon we loved
as a kid will soon be back
to remind us of a time when life
was like a box of chocolates.
On the horizon, we got new
installments of DuckTales,
We got your Animaniacs,
your Hey Arnold!
-Rocko's Modern Life.
-(cheers and applause)
Where...
-TOM KENNY: That was a hoot!
-The updated titular...
-(laughter)
-The updated tit...
-Did you do a voice on Rocko's
Modern...? -KENNY: I did.
-That was my first series.
Heffer. Yeah. -You were Heffer.
(applause and cheering)
-HARDWICK: You were Heffer.
-I'm in the spotlight.
HARDWICK: Anyway,
this is all updated, and
the updated character will
reportedly listen to dubstep
and pound energy drinks.
Basically, everything you'd do
at a baby shower in New Jersey.
So, comedians,
if classic cartoon characters
keep getting crammed
down our modern age holes,
what is the plot line
of a reboot
that you would like to see?
Uh, Brandon.
Uh, Fat Albert goes to jail
for what he did to those women.
HARDWICK:
All right.
-Points.
-(cheers and applause)
Yup.
-(as Fat Albert): Hey, hey.
Oops! -(laughter)
HARDWICK:
Tom Kenny.
He-Man can't serve
in the armed forces
-'cause he used to be She-Ra.
-All right, points. Very good.
-(applause and cheering)
-Points.
(in cartoon voice): By the power
of Castle Pig Skull.
HARDWICK:
Dan Harmon.
Thundercats, but with dogs,
so Dog-cats is...
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Yes, points.
-...what I'm pitching.
-Yeah. -HARDWICK: Yes.